la présidente de région portera-t-elle
bientôt un masque chirurgical 100%
bourgogne franche comté et nos fabriqués
en asie l'idée n'a rien de saugrenu
souvenez vous en mars dernier la préfète
d'une région voisine réquisitionnait
sans crier gare des centaines de
milliers de masques destinés à la
bourgogne franche comté trail est chaude
et marie-guite dufay ne pouvait en
rester là
au mois de mai dernier dans la plus
grande discrétion elle achète cette
machine 300000 euros en turquie et la
faire rapatrier par camions à travers
l'europe
une histoire rocambolesque avec un
objectif assurer définitivement
l'autonomie de la région
moi j'ai tiré les leçons de ce que nous
venons de vivre depuis quatre mois et
donc qu'une collectivité comme une
région se dote d'un stop stratégique de
masques chirurgicaux pour les hôpitaux
ça me semble pouvoir relever de notre
responsabilité
le robot industriel certains n'y croient
pas écrit même au scandale dans le
territoire de belfort le sénateur cédric
perrin dénonce l'abandon de toute une
filière
ces centaines de salariés petit soldat
de la couture mobilisés pour fabriquer
des masques puis abandonnés par les
pouvoirs publics
on a écrit et ses écosystèmes sur
l'habitant du versant de la région je
suis persuadé aujourd'hui qui vivrait
encore que les 200 personnes qui
aujourd'hui pointe au chômage sont
salariés de l'entreprise pour peut-être
pu voir leurs emplois perdus et c'est en
ça que en lisant le journal lire match
parce que je trouve ça complètement
alger cédric perrin parle bien de masque
en tissu réutilisables certes aux normes
mais marie-guite dufay elles visent des
masques en polypropylène les seuls
autorisés dans les hôpitaux pour les
soignants la mise en route de la machine
est prévue pour septembre
elle est calibré pour sortir six cent
mille masques par semaine remis
gratuitement aux hôpitaux